nicht nur darüber sondern auch über ein
paar andere dinge möchte ich sehr gerne
mit meinen beiden gästen sprechen
erneuten ist bei mir von der afg der
bundessprecher im grunde der
parteivorsitzende und neben ihm katrin
göring eckardt die fraktionsvorsitzende
der grünen herzlich willkommen
frau göring-eckardt sie kommen aus
thüringen sie haben in sachsen studiert
sie machen jetzt seit jahren politik ist
ihnen da in den letzten jahren
tatsächlich irgendetwas durchgegangen
welche fehler haben sie gemacht dass ich
diese wut da so aufgestaut hat ich
glaube es gibt ja auf der einen seite
die wut die sie jetzt gezeigt haben in
dem film auf der anderen seite gibt es
ja in dem gleichen ort in chemnitz eine
ganze reihe von aufrechten bürgern die
dort für die demokratie kämpfen und wenn
sie fragen was habe ich versäumt oder
was hat haben andere in der provence
oder unterschätzt dann würde ich sagen
ja wir haben nicht ausreichend gesehen
dass es in ostdeutschland viel zu viele
menschen gibt die mit enttäuschung mit
frust mit einer erfahrung von verlust in
den letzten 28 jahren unterwegs sind
alles hat angefangen glaube ich mit der
treuhand und damit dass im grunde
genommen von westdeutschland aus alles
übernommen worden ist ich bin im osten
aufgewachsen ich hab immer gedacht
irgendwann wird sich das erledigt haben
das wird sie schon so zusammenwachsen
und man muss jetzt gar nicht immerzu von
dem osten reden das glaube ich bis heute
aber diese erfahrungen finde ich müssen
wir thematisieren uns muss klar sein es
gibt menschen die haben die letzten
jahre nicht als etwas positives
empfunden obwohl freiheit obwohl
verbesserung von vieler art von
lebensbedingungen der fall was man von
den menschen vor ort immer wieder hört
ist klar das was sie gerade auch
angesprochen haben die enteignung dass
die renten noch nicht angeglichen wurden
gebrochene biografien und vieles vieles
mehr auch der ein bisschen der sagt mal
der arrogante westen der immer so ein
bisschen stiefmütterlich gen osten
geguckt hat das ist ja sind viele dinge
die einem die menschen dort erreichen
haben sie aber auch verständnis
tatsächlich für die wut und ich rede
jetzt noch nicht das müssen wir hier
fein sauber trennen über die die im
grunde wirklich [ __ ] klatschen
gerufen haben die heil hitler gerufen
haben und den nazis aber ich rede
wirklich über die anderen haben sie für
diese wut verständnis ihr verständnis
für enttäuschung ich habe verständnis
für frust und ich habe an manchen
stellen auch verständnis für gut na klar
also hat leute gegeben die sind
arbeitslos geworden anfang der 90er sind
dann von einer umschulungsmaßnahme in
die nächste bekommen und die hatten
effektive dass sie in diesem gemeinsamen
land mehr ankommen und dann wurden sie
irgendwie von anderen aus
westdeutschland auch noch damit
konfrontiert dass dies eben nun mal
besser wissen also dafür habe ich total
viel verständnis wenn es umkippt wenn es
darum geht dass man jemanden schuldig
machen will der überhaupt nichts damit
zu tun hat und das sind dann im
zweifelsfall immer die geflüchteten das
da ist ja wollten irgendwie mal an der
spitze dass man die dann auch zuständig
macht für das was in unserem land
passiert ist dann habe ich kein
verständnis mehr dafür sondern dann sage
ich nein
dagegen trete ich an und da treten gegen
trete ich auch auf ermorden
entschuldigen sie
entschuldigen sie oder erklären sie den
rassismus den wir aber auch in teilen
eben dort gesehen haben tatsächlich mit
einem tötungsdelikt was ja noch genau
aufzuklären ist von wem ist dann
eigentlich begangen wurde
ich entschuldige und relativiere gar
keinen rassismus das ist indiskutabel
da beißt die maus keinen faden ab und
ich denke dass alle demokraten diese
position haben und der
fraktionsvorsitzende alexander gauland
hat sich ja in den letzten tagen auch
häufig geäußert und er sagte unter
anderem eine wenn eine solche tötung
star passiert ist es normal dass
menschen ausrasten sehen sie das
tatsächlich auch so
also ich kann ich kann wirklich die
menschen verstehen weil sie sehr kenne
kein einzelfall werden eigentlich
hunderte von einzelfällen und ich kann
verstehen dass das sicherheitsgefühl der
menschen das kann auch in dem beitrag
schon deutlich heraus massiv angekratzt
ist weil wir sicherheit verlieren weil
wir die zustände haben die wir haben und
ich kann absolut verstehen wenn tausende
von menschen dann friedlich auf die
straße gehen und demonstrieren
ich kann erst recht verstehen dass sie
einen trauermarsch machen zu tausenden
solange sich das friedrich vollzieht so
lange dabei keine schlimmen dinge
gemacht werden ist das vollständig in
ordnung und wird von uns auch
vollständig unterstützt und ich muss
ihnen sagen dass ich dass ich wirklich
empört bin die sehr man die menschen da
jetzt stigmatisiert reden sie mal mit
menschen in sachsen sie haben es ja
getan
die sind die sind außer sich und sie
sind es berechtigterweise weil er einem
ganzen bundesland unterstellt wird sie
würden hetzjagd betreiben von
zusammenrottung redet frau merkel und
weiß offenkundig nicht wovon sie spricht
denn das hat das so nicht gegeben da
habe ich da kurzmann gern rang
wer sagt dass alle sachsen rechtsextreme
sind oder alle in chemnitz wer hat das
je getan ich habe das auch vor ort ganz
oft gehört und man steht an der
fassungslos da wir versuchen zu
differenzieren da haben wir gerade auch
getan indem man ganz nah sagt es gibt
die besorgten bürger die mit gelaufen
sind und dann gibt es die ganz klar zu
identifizieren
neonazis also wer wäre denn alle saxo
sind plötzlich rechtsradikale gar nicht
jedem sagen zum beispiel jakob augstein
an ihnen auch bekannter kolumnist der
empfahl man sollte vielleicht seien an
den grenzen sachsens
schilder aufstellen willkommen in
sachsen wollte dann aber s und a groß
schreiben damit wieder ein ganzes land
quasi als nazis diffamiert oder nehmen
sie den neuen spieletitel vom samstag
kann sich jeder am kiosk anschauen ihre
parteikollegin übrigens meinte seitz
sensor wenn ihr sachsen das dann nicht
mehr als frau roth wenn die sachsen das
dann nicht mehr amperas verkaufen wollen
weil die so die nase voll davon haben
weil ihm also wenn wir über fake news
sprechen dann können aber ihnen anfangen
kann weil frau merkel anfangen frau
merkel redet von hetzjagd und ihr
eigener parteikollege die eigene
parteikollegen kretschmann sagte heute
hetzjagden hat es nicht gegeben
es hat keine zusammengerottet doch und
herr seibert liefert die machen hier
ganz massiv aid und ihre partner ist ja
noch hoch spezialisiert darauf aber
vielleicht eine frage an sie gerne
hetzjagd wie auch immer man das
bezeichnet was da stattgefunden hat wir
haben bilder gesehen von menschen die
andere menschen angegriffen haben die
hast ihr hetze auf die straße getrieben
haben die menschen verfolgt haben egal
wie lange und egal wie weit finden sie
das in ordnung ja oder nein das ist die
frage die ich in stelle keine andere ist
das in ordnung was wir da gesehen haben
ja oder nein da ist das wahrscheinlich
ist das nicht in ordnung sein aber damit
überhaupt nichts zu tun auch der umwelt
gemacht ist dann zum beispiel meiner
partei unterstellen wir hätten damit
irgendetwas zu tun ist wenn ihr etwas
sagen die afg hat genau zweimal
demonstriert nämlich einmal am sonntag
nach der tat mit 100 leuten für eine
stunde absolut friedlich und dann hat
sie einen trauermarsch gemacht da wird
dann aufgerufen kampf gegen nazis und
ähnliches mehr
und sie sind lustvoll dabei uns in diese
ecke zu stellen aus ihrer partei kommen
anwürfe wir sollten einfach
verfassungsschutz beobachtung gestellt
werden dann schauen sie sich mal an was
sie selbst sagen was ihre parteikollegin
roth sagt was ihr parteivorsitzender
habeck sagt und dann können wir noch mal
über verfassungsschutz selber im winter
gerne drüber den leistungsschutz reden
wir gleich noch ich würde gerne noch
ganz noch einmal darauf zurückkommen
erstens haben sie jetzt gerade gesagt
sie distanzieren sich erneuten und auf
der anderen seite haben wir aber und ich
war ja auch da bei dem trauermarsch
gesehen ganz vorne war jörn höcke zu
sehen also aus der afc und leben ihn
sehen wir aber auch neben dem oder
beziehungsweise hinter dem arm
das ist wird's bachmann das wissen wir
alle der gehört zur bg dann eigentlich
gibt es doch bei ihnen auch ja sagen wir
mal die tendenz zu sagen wir gehören
nicht zusammen wie so marschieren sie
mit päda und auch anderen wir hatten den
experten gerade im film gesehen der
konnte die besser identifizieren als ich
dem also frei teilgruppen und ich weiß
nicht wie viele verschiedene gruppen ist
mittlerweile gibt also warum
distanzieren sie sich dann nicht nur
eine randbemerkung amanda ist wird bei
uns immer gesagt wir marschieren die
anderen demonstrieren wir marschieren
damit sich das mal trainieren sondern
wäre wirklich
doch dieses geschenk machen wir aber
sehr traurig er trauer x naja gut na ja
gut das wort markieren mit dem jeweils
anderen sprachlos gemacht
schauen sie die ard meldet ein thomas
anders ist eine öffentliche
veranstaltung haben versammlungsgesetzes
dem kann sich anschließen wer will die
pgw hat sich dem angeschlossen und ich
muss ihnen auch sagen
dieser umgang mit päda der der gefällt
mir auch nicht richtig nein wir machen
mit denen nicht gemeinsame sache um das
um das klar zu sagen aber wenn wir ein
gemeinsames anliegen haben und wenn er
sich dazu entschließt mit uns gemeinsam
da diesen trauer markt jetzt auch wenn
ich selber zu veranstalten dann ist das
so dass das finde ich auch legitim ist
sind ja übrigens vielleicht auch wenn
mir wenn wir eine demonstration machen
auch andere leute dabei wir achten
peinlich darauf dass dass es friedlich
bleibt soweit man das irgendwann dass
irgendwelche leute damit gehen die sich
daran nicht halten aber das hier ist
übrigens nicht sehen wir das fleisch
direkt friedlich sie haben ja mit pegah
auch zusammen aufgerufen es gibt ja auch
das plakat also wo das logo an der afg
zu sehen ist ja unter nebendran das
pedal logo und es gab eigentlich bei dem
beschluss dass es das von afg sei nicht
geben soll also es dürfte ihnen doch
nicht nur nicht gefallen sondern das
müssten sie doch eigentlich unterbinden
also das haben wir einmal parteiintern
auch durchaus diskutiert aber der
sächsische landesverband dafür zuständig
ist weil es in sachsen nur mal ist der
hat sich dazu entschlossen das zu tun
und ich finde das kann man auch tun und
wenn sie diese diese verquickung
kritisch sehen das dürfen sie da muss
ich ihnen aber sagen
untersuchen sie doch mal seitens der
medien überhaupt die verquickung etwa
der
linksaußen parteien wie grüne linke und
so weiter mit dem anti familie da haben
sie es mit gewalttätern zu tun da haben
sie es mit leuten zu frau göring-eckardt
ja die kommt auf die grandiose idee und
schreibt yes ihr seid groß und meint
damit feine sahne fischfilet ja wie
finden sie groß dass das immer auch
scheine seine fische leben
feine sahne fischfilet die bullen helme
sie sollen fliegen eure knüppelkrieg der
in die fresse rein
die nächste bullen wache ist nur einen
steinwurf entfernt deutschland verrecke
das wäre wunderbar das finden sie groß
genauso wie ihre parteifreundin dorothea
in demonstrationszügen mit geht auf den
skandiert wird deutschland verrecke
deutschland und dieses stück scheiße
gemacht und herr habeck sagt
vaterlandsliebe fand ich stets zum
kotzen
mit deutschlandweit wusste ich nichts
anzufangen weiß dass bis heute nicht und
dann kommt ihre partei und erzählt heute
einen von heimatliebe das ist perfide
ist doch was sie veranstalten und das
bei ihnen masche in diesem ganzen
brasiliens auch im geschwätz da würde
ich dir mal ein bisschen genauer gucken
auch in ihrer nicht abgrenzung zum anti
familie keller hängt sich eine anti
verfahren um das sind leute die greifen
uns kürzlich an die schlagen leute
krankenhausreif
das ist ihr milieu vielleicht sollte man
bei ihnen mal über verfassungen und
nicht gezwungen alles gesagt nur noch
nicht
linksgrün versucht dass alle anderen die
er ja gerade geäußert hat und das sind
ja nun wirklich zitate die auch wirklich
so gefallen sind alle aus uns diese
bilder
wir haben nachdem während des
g20-gipfels ja auch gesehen dass die
grüne jugend sich mit der
interventionistischen linken
solidarisiert hat also hat er da mit dem
punkt also wenn gewalt passiert dann
habe ich damit nichts zu tun ich bin
1989 auf die straße gegangen bei einer
friedlichen revolution das war übrigens
wirklich eine da ist nicht wie bei herrn
sauerland der die jetzt gerade aus ruft
der erste wagen wollte jetzt wieder
vertreiben wahrscheinlich solche leute
die mich doch mal von antifa raab macht
nochmal so haben wir wollen mit euch
nichts zu tun haben ihr seid gewalt
fertig machen sind von mir dauernd rein
quatschen kann ich überhaupt nichts
machen ich wissen
[Applaus]
ich habe mit gewalt nichts zu tun ich
muss mich davon auch nicht distanzieren
ich kann mir muss ich auch nicht ich
sage einfach ich lehne gewalt ab in
jeder form
das ist egal wo es stattfindet egal wo
es stattfindet und das gab traf g20
genauso wie andere sachen die vorher
passiert sind und ich habe das immer
gemacht ich werde das auch immer weiter
tun die den text den sie vorgelesen
haben die band über die da um die da die
rede geht hat selbst gesagt da sehen sie
heute anders und darum habe ich gesagt
wenn jemand eine haltung hat wenn jemand
sein denken verändert wenn jemand sein
handeln verändert dann habe ich dafür
höchsten respekt wovor ich keinen
respekt auf java ist am montag gesunken
ich lasse dich extra darf ich ja gar
nicht zu ändern die machen das nach
wieder dass linkshänder also bitteschön
nein das sind nicht linksradikale die
bands die da am montag gesungen haben
und die 65.000 menschen die da auf der
straße gewesen sind übrigens vollkommen
friedlich die eine schweigeminute
gemacht haben und die die schweigeminute
ernst gemeint haben die nicht versucht
haben das andenken von verstorbenen zu
verunglimpfen
das gilt nämlich für daniel h genauso
wie für sofia die verwandten gesagt
haben das was da passiert ist
das hat mit den menschen die da
gestorben sind die da umgebracht worden
sind nichts zu tun das müssen sie sich
sagen lassen erneuten dass jesus ich
will dass sie das müssen sie sich sagen
lassen weil sie das andenken der
verstorbenen missbrauchen ja natürlich
weiter sie ihr auto und in leben und
links konzert nein sie war wo diese
steilvorlage jahren eben leider keine
rockkonzerte eine friedliche menschen
aufstehen und haltung zeigen sondern
weil sie machen es im parlament zu
sitzen
im baden württembergischen landtag zu
sitzen einen antisemiten zu schützen
herrn hüppe zu schützen in der partei in
der sie sind der mitglieder gemeinsame
sache macht und findet dass die gewalt
aufrufe schon ganz in ordnung sind mit
einem drogen wegen drogenmissbrauchs
angeklagten herr bachmann auf der straße
steht und wo sein bester traum in
erfüllung geht das pedal und die afg
sich zusammenschließen das machen sie
und damit spalten sie unser land genau
damit spalten sie unserer heimat wenn
man seine heimat liebt dann spaltet man
nicht an ruft man nicht dazu
auch gegen die anderen auf die straße zu
gehen sondern das miteinander jahre und
genau darum geht es ja wort soja im
baden württembergischen landtag ja da
hat in ihrer antwort da hat die partei
der grünen einen untersuchungsausschuss
den wir beantragt haben zu den
wirklichen terroraktionen in hamburg
verweigerten wissen sie warum die
verteidiger dannenberg zu haben wird
rechnen dabei etwas nein wir wollten
wissen wer es waren etwa 1000 leute aus
baden württemberg
da und wir wollten wissen wer hat das
finanziert meinen sie ihre partei hätte
den bann ziehen wissen sie warum
passiert das geht jetzt zwar ein video
wurde aus der fraktion ausgeschlossen
was wissen sie und dass wir wieder was
sie haben da ich gesagt und der
touristik haben wohl wissend dass wohl
wissend dass ein 1 3 aus dem etat
sondergleichen keine ahnung von war ich
es gibt in baden verteidigt überhaupt
keine kleine keine liste die wolken die
regen wollte einmal wie so oft dumme
zeugen mit zurück zur sache ist
schüttler
das heißt keine liste ist doch aber das
versteht sie trotzdem könnten die
demokratie ganz kurz ich weiß wir können
drei stunden über gott und die welt
diskutiert aber ich würde gerne wieder
zurück zur sache kommen zu den wirklich
ernst zu nehmenden vorfällen in chemnitz
angefangen bei dem schlimmen wir wissen
nicht ob es mord war totschlag das wird
sich alles noch klären
und was wir dann eben bei den
demonstrationen bei dem trauermarsch in
teilen gesehen haben
es gibt nun mal die bilder wo menschen
den rechten arm heben es gibt auch jagd
auf menschen es gibt davon bilder ich
habe mit augenzeugen auch vor ort
gesprochen ob man das so ein hetzjagd
mengen muss jetzt müssen hier keine
keine semantik betreiben aber das ist
passiert dass dort menschen mit
migrations vordergrund oder die anders
aussagen auch verfolgt worden sind
deswegen meine frage an sie hätten was
tun sie gegen rechtsextremismus dann
zunächst einmal wir tolerieren in
unserer eigenen partei wir haben immer
wieder erlebt dass ich menschen bemüht
haben in unserer partei fuß zu fassen
die diesem milieu angehören wir haben
sie konsequent alle immer aus der partei
entfernt und wir tun das überaus
erfolgreich und wir gucken da sehr viel
genauer hin bei der partei aufnahme als
andere parteien das tun über die partei
hinaus also in der gesellschaft gibt es
samy deluxe hat ja gesagt für sommer
überhaupt ja eigentlich die letzten 30
jahre gelebt rassismus gibt es immer und
zwar jeden tag gerade für jemand mit
einer anderen hautfarbe und er weiß
wovon er spricht was tun sie um die
gesellschaft sozusagen
ich glaube nicht dass wir uns davon
befreien können aber ein denn was tut
ihre partei wir arbeiten daran dass wir
ein gesellschaftspolitisches klima
bekommen dass mit dieser regierung
freilich nicht geht wir können relativ
wenig gestalten weil wir wissen wir sind
das wissen sie in der opposition in der
opposition können die politik nicht gut
auch im untersuchungsausschuss zum
rechtsextremismus machen nicht nur zum
linksextrem es ich bin wie ich bin
sofort dabei wenn wir
untersuchungsausschüsse
untersuchungsausschusses untersuchen
behörden versagen und ich bin sofort
dabei wenn der untersuchungsausschüsse
sowohl zum linksextremismus als auch
rechtsextremisten haben beides ist
gleichermaßen abzusehen war mir sofort
los oder fein baden württemberg war doch
2016 haben sie ja einen antrag
eingebracht haben sie eben sonja genau
aber sie haben eingebracht zum
linksextremisten nach der linksextremist
jetzt könnte man ein zu
rechtsextremistischen gewalt ein
aber dazu müssen wir erst mal mehr
rechtsextremistische gewalt haben wir
haben extrem viele erst ein
rechtsextremistischer gewalt vielmehr
als linke politisch motivierte gewalt
ist bei den rechtsextremen sagen die
zahlen von der polizei vom
verfassungsschutz höher als die bonner
wollen wir wirklich über die polizei
kriminalitätsstatistik reden wollen wir
nicht aber die zahlen 13 jahren
aufzunehmen das kann ich ihnen aber
jetzt mal was wollen sie tun
zum thema streichen sie das ist ständig
bestreitet das das ist rechtsextreme
gewalt nein das beschleunigt das haben
wir doch gesehen dass das bestreite ich
massiv über die linksextreme wird nicht
berichtet wenn mein parteifreund uwe
junge von antifa leuten zu
geschlagen wird dass er mehrere
operationen hat dann wird darüber
schlicht nicht berichtet wenn unsere
häuser angegriffen werden mit
farbbeuteln verunstaltet werden wenn
unsere autos abgefackelt wird wenn
radmuttern gelöst werden und die leute
setzten sich anschließend rein dann wird
darüber in den deutschen medien nicht
berichtet das ok das steht das heißt das
ist im grund das glaubt ihnen kein
mensch wir können es ja belegen dass es
so ist also ein verfassungsschutzbericht
ich sehe sie jetzt einmal 2017 politisch
motivierte kriminalität links sechs 1393
rechts 16.400 67 jetzt können wir lange
über den verfassungsschutz reden das
treffen aller kult in aller kürze wollen
wir das auch noch unterbringen
denn jetzt gibt es die debatte katrin
göring eckardt soll die afg vom
verfassungsschutz beobachtet werden ja
oder nein
über 50 prozent der deutschen sagen ja
die grünen sagen auch ja warum
eigentlich bei den linken wollten sie es
nicht
also wir sagen der verfassungsschutz
muss ja erstmal selber entscheiden aber
es spricht sehr viel dafür in hamburg
hat der verfassungsschutz der
landesverfassungsschutz um den geht ja
dann immer gerade gesagt es hat eine
anmeldung zu einer demonstration gegeben
eine merkel muss weg demonstration und
es wurde festgestellt dass die anmelder
nachweislich sehr enge kontakte zu amd
haben und deswegen hat der hamburger
verfassungsschutz gesagt diesen connex
gibt es und deswegen muss beobachtet
werden wenn ich mir das anschaue was es
an verbindungen gegeben hat auch in
chemnitz auch bei diesen demonstrationen
dann sage ich dann muss der
verfassungsschutz die ich damit
beschäftigen ich bin jetzt kein fan vom
verfassungsschutz ich hab da auch nicht
wahnsinnig viel vertrauen insbesondere
wenn ich mir anschaue dass der chef des
verfassungsschutzes scheinbar immer
wieder gespräche mit afd vertretern für
das ist nicht der punkt wo ich sage da
wird sich irgendwas tatsächlich
verbessern und da werden wir tatsächlich
große aufklärung finden aber wenn der
hamburger verfassungsschutz
beispielsweise sowas feststellt ist es
wichtig da so sieht man wenn menschen
der demonstration anmelden
das haben sie gerade gesagt und dann
stellt sich heraus die haben kontakt zu
afd dann gehört denn gerade die person
also ich hab ja das muss her dass der
landesverfassung kurz gesagt hat und er
hat von rechtsextremen personen geredet
diesen kontakt haben und wenn diese
connex besteht zu rechtsextremen person
dann hat der verfassungsschutz in
hamburg offensichtlich da hab ich ja
jetzt nicht ich bin auch dadurch gar
nicht mitglied der monster nicht darauf
verständigen dass wenn linksradikale
hier meine g20 in hamburg die halbe
stadt in schutt und asche legen ist das
album übrigens ist das ganze ja das ist
furchtbar dass wir dann da vielleicht
auch mal schauen wer die unterstützt hat
das kann ich ihnen nicht sagen
spd grüne linke diese verleihung gibt es
und das wollen wir kommen aber zeigt das
ist niemand spd grünen oder linken hat
gewaltexzesse in hamburg in einer weise
unterstützt sondern im gegenteil im
gegen die leute daher dem das kann ich
jemand mit bezahlten mussten uns an
dieser stelle
wann witzmann strich drunter das wird
ihm ja genauso unterstellt und von
unterstellungen haben wir jetzt auch
genug ich finde das war ein ganz guter
streit hier in diesem sinne zum thema
auf diesem sofa und ich glaube wir sind
uns alle einig weder links noch rechts
rechtsextremismus geht und alle menschen
die auf die straßen gehen
die sich für sagen wir mal eine offene
tolerante gesellschaft einsetzen und
gegen die extrem demonstrieren die muss
man gar nicht erst in boxen packen
sondern das sind alles gestandene
demokraten so in diesem sinne danke für
dieses gespräch
[Applaus]